from the daily wires as well says a
buffalo based lesbian couple is suing
cny fertility clinic
in new york for allegedly giving them
the wrong embryo
heather wilhelm rautenberg and robin
rautenberg wilhelm explicitly requested
that they have a baby daughter after
undergoing fertility treatments however
the couple was devastated to find out
that they were expecting a son
now they're responding with legal action
against the fertility clinic claiming
that heather became suicidal after her
son's birth and entered a dark
depression upon finding out that she was
carrying a baby boy
um upon first finding out the child was
male at her 15-week appointment heather
said she became convinced the ivf clinic
mixed up the embryos and she was
actually carrying somebody else's baby
heather told amy klein at the post i
looked at robbie and said what if it's
not yours who's in my body that's when i
flipped out that's when i felt my body
was taken hostage
um
continuing uh we scheduled an ultrasound
for the next day that was the worst
night of my life i had this overwhelming
sense of immobility i remember lying in
my bedroom thinking this can't be
happening not only was the baby in my
body not our not ours but the baby in my
body was male and he was put there
against my will just like rape
um and then it goes on i can't even
continue reading this entire thing it's
so disgusting
but
they you know gave birth to the to the
child
and now they're saying it's it's as if
she was raped so who
is the rapist in this analogy
the baby
i suppose that's what it's looked at how
it seemed now she says that this child
was putting my body against my will of
course that's not the case at all
you very much chose to undergo this
procedure
and this is one of the consequences of
when we treat
human life like a commodity
and we treat conception like some sort
of science experiment that we do in a
petri dish
okay
this is one of the consequences and i
don't mean consequence of embryos could
get mixed up or whatever and you don't
get exactly what you ordered ordered i
mean that is one of the consequences but
just think about the way we're talking
about this you ordered it like it's a
catalog like you ordered a you know
jacket from l.l bean or something this
is human life
and the real consequence is that you
start to see human life as a commodity
and then what you get the wrong one
quote unquote and you want to return it
and you're suing because it was a you
know a mistake in the customer service
end of things
treating human life like a commodity
that's the consequence
and where it all becomes about you right
so for this lesbian couple
um the child is all about them
they're having this child to serve their
own emotional needs it's not about the
child
it's not about loving the child and
caring for the child it's about them
and they also believe
and this is another problem with
you know
the surrogacy ivf all this stuff
is that it carries with it this idea
that you have a right we talked about
this last week
it's like this idea that you have you
have a right to a child
when in fact you don't
now if you have a child as a parent then
you have a right to care for your
children it does not have that
superseded by the government those are
your parental rights
but you don't have an underlying human
right to have a child to begin with
that's not a right that exists but
that's the way we see it now
and so these women thought well i have a
right i have a right to a child and then
i get the i get quote the wrong one well
my rights have been infringed upon and
so now you have to pay me so that's the
consequence of treating human life like
it's a commodity this is just one it's
one of the more egregious examples but
we see it all the time in our society
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated